joe biden turning into the democratic
party's pariah the president's sinking
in the polls he's being trashed by
allies in the press and now members of
his own party don't want to be seen in
public with the guy
i know how that feels
the president was in ohio but
high-profile democrats running for
office in that state skipped the visit
due to quote scheduling conflicts
those dems didn't miss much however
biden did his usual blathering about
putin and evil republicans as he tried
to spin his failures
previous administration lost more jobs
in his watch
than any administration since herbert
hoover what is a republican platform
going to this campaign
no no i'm i'm in deadly earnest i'm not
trying to be polite just just a fact we
got a long way to go because of
inflation because of
the i call it the putin tax increase
putin because of gasoline republicans do
nothing to obstruct our efforts to lower
your gas taxes
[Music]
that's funny
biden is continuing his slide into a
toxic stew of mediocrity and liberals
just don't see a 79 year old fossil as a
fighter
one summing it up this way quote he's
missing the boat here this is our time
to dig in and be absolutely furious
because these one-half measures are not
working he's got a real excitability
problem and then cnn sees more scheduled
conflicts in biden's future
i think we should get used to the term
scheduling conflicts is that going to
happen i mean you know democrats say mr
president please do these things he does
them and they're not there to cheer them
on
dana dana no much there so much there
and that leads me to my the question i
keep bringing up is this a typical
problem that a party has when they're in
the white house or is this exponentially
worse this is exponentially worse and i
think we're going to break some records
here because he's losing his base
he's losing the progressives he's losing
the moderates and he's really losing a
lot of the youth vote and i read
something very interesting today
obviously there's some frustration from
the left about the supreme court
decision on roe v wade but they also
think that president biden hasn't fought
enough right they want more fighting but
they also have started to do this
immediately on the day of roe v wade
being announced
the democrats started sending out
fundraising appeals
and it really irritated them like we've
we worked hard to try to get you elected
and the first thing you do when a bad
decision comes down is ask us for money
in addition you have a columnist like
dana milbank at the washington post
saying just give biden a break he's
really done everything that you asked
him to do and in some ways you think
they have no one to blame but themselves
right um i think this downward spiral
could lead to uh seeing him not just in
the mid 30s where he is now but in the
low 30s
and so
they're looking at a disaster and i
would add one last thing
they they want the president to be
furious but fury doesn't equal
persuasion yeah and it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're going to
actually achieve anything if you're mad
right that makes sense yes do you think
there's something else no
because i still we're on the air greg
i i thought you were gonna say something
after that but then you just stopped and
that that that made me feel very awkward
so i'm gonna go to you harold uh because
in the green room you said greg i don't
think i've ever seen a democratic
president in such a sorry state in my
life and you must be working and you
must be working out greg
which made me feel a little
uncomfortable no look dana's dana's
largely right about this i would add
this democrats
who want to separate from the president
uh running for public office and tim
ryan who's an old friend and an old
colleague
look i i i give i give candidates to
benefit the doubt if he believes that
campaigning other parties said it's the
right thing to help him when you got to
let him do that but if you're joe biden
you know that these things are being
said about you you know that there's
some concerns about you in a party
if you're going to go to ohio or
california wherever you got to have a
reason for going other than trying to
just defend things that people don't
think are working you got to come with
as dana says sometimes you got you got
to come in a real real event a new
policy a new approach
wouldn't have been great to go to ohio
and talk about intel and talk about a
position change on energy would it be
great to go to california and talk about
a position change on crime and the kinds
of things we're going to say to da's
across the country
if you do the same old things my
grandmother told me you're going to get
the same old results
and i just hope that the president
realizes that campaigns are about the
future people want to know what you're
going to do differently and if you get
if democrats remain in power what is it
that everyday voters can expect
differently in their lives that's what i
would be focused on if i were them uh i
do think it's hard to separate from the
president though if he's in your own
party and you're running for senator
running for public office so i think
these everybody's got to get together
and figure out what is it that we want
to project to the country and how do we
project that not by defending the things
that aren't working but saying here's
what we're going to do differently and
this is why it's going to work and with
the democratic senate in congress i can
make it work short of that it's hard it
is hard when your party hates america
harold
nobody you don't hate america
judge shouldn't biden be freaking out
because if the if the democrats lose the
house it's going to be
hearings 24 7 hunter biden hearings i've
already ordered the party platter
i mean it's not just the hunter biden
hearings i mean they're going after
everybody at this point look
to what harold was just saying i think
joe biden went to ohio didn't he talk
about pension plans and protecting the
pension plans people are worried about
gas so that they can afford to go to
work so that they can afford to put food
on the table you don't have to be a
genius you don't have to call people
together to say gee let's figure out
what to talk about here and you know
what he's doing what i found so shocking
he kind of snuck it in there biden says
you know all the grain that putin is
keeping from getting to market what he's
doing there is he's preemptively blaming
putin for the food shortage that we're
going to have in this country and he's
like teeing it up so he can say i told
you it was coming but you wanted
democracy in the ukraine you wanted
those higher gas prices because you
believe in democracy look the guy is a
lot more than just a guy who is a
political liability he is a political
embarrassment he is a political
embarrassment which is why they don't
want to show up with him and i agree
with dana i think that even though he's
36 percent now in the in terms of
approval it's going to go lower than
that and there isn't anything that this
man is capable of doing every time he
gets on a stage and he speaks i don't
believe what he's saying and america
doesn't believe it either
jesse are the republicans in danger of
buying into the red wave so much so that
they don't bother to do the work they're
just assuming that people are going to
vote against the democrats well that's
why i don't say red wave and they could
coast and just say i'm against
everything that joe biden's doing and
still do pretty well but you know
they'll have the debates and they'll do
well in the states the president has to
be a good storyteller
and
his story doesn't make any sense what
about corn pop
those are good stories yes
but the story the political story he's
selling no one's buying because you
can't say trump had a bad economy the
best economy in 50 years he turned the
economy off because of covet he can't
blame republicans for blocking his
agenda
democrats control everything in
washington he can't say he's got a great
economy no one believes that and then he
can't say putin price hike well he's not
doing anything to end the war
which would bring prices down so
when a president is clicking on all
cylinders his story is the same story as
his party story as the same story is
being told as it partners in the media
the democrats aren't saying
buy electric cars putin price psych not
even cnn is buying into that garbage
adam schiff talks about january 6 he
doesn't talk about gas
that's when you know things are a
problem they have these calls with the
white house and the democratic party
that democrats get on the phone with the
white house and they're like can you
guys give us some better talking points
because these talking points aren't
working and they're actually out in the
streets selling this thing so they know
these things are garbage
right now
everybody knows the reason joe biden got
elected was because of covid and trump
fatigue
he was never a talented politician he
got lucky
and now his luck has run out and he
can't stand on his own and people need
to recognize that
there you go all right up next
liberal city crime outrage violent
criminals set free while a man who
fought for his life winds up in jail i
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now